hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to prison Island now this is
a horror game that's currently in
development it's actually free okay it's
free so it's not even like early access
but is supposedly when you're stuck on
an island and you're trying to not die
yes I think they're 600's genome ir
machine yeah the violas sound she reads
oh wait no it's okay all right
okay Prison Island I get it all right
whoa it's an island and it's a prison I
get it very scary
all right whoa I landed with quite a
slump
hello there's weird boxes in the sky
okay Oh what is that what am i seen oh
I've got two frames a second oh boy okay
a little strange what the hell is
happening here why you rumbling so
bumbly
weight yarn all rumbly bum blue oh I
can't read that what does that say
everybody okay all right kind of
slenderman's about lulz fern and it
Lewis
I thought that I said lols my bad
I've been on the Internet whoa what the
height hey stop that now
okay all right well okay here we go just
needed whoever's blowing into that tuba
needed to take a breath
laughs just you why why why why
would you do that
Nene six Lex all right well if you say
Nene are you doing that it's better not
just be a jump-scare haunted house
walking simulator edge up care why I die
okay all right not that bad not that bad
not that bad you can have to do better
than that to get me I've had a lot of
experience with jump scares scares that
are jumpy strange who's ringing the
chimes who's China run up a storm over
there
Oh Oh whines oh that was a cool effect
I will admit but why though is my
curious statement why they're always a
doozy always it ding-dong
damn doozy maybe this maybe there's like
more stuff I've actually going to the
like corners of these rooms or something
nice bars no nice growth no okay
lies all lies weird
that was funkalicious that was something
that I've never seen before I mean
obviously this game on its surface it's
rough around the edges
and it needs a lot of polish but hey at
least it's got the ambiance down whoo
all right Oh Daniel Suarez ex-military
32 years old
kidnapping political crime smuggling
subversion crime pronouncement the
prisoner wha taken to sell aid for
interrogation okay
ah damn my flashbacks what the hell
wait a minute that wasn't was that like
that before and it's not just you the
frame rates a little low in the game and
I don't know why it's not even taxing my
system very much but there she wait yeah
what the hell oh I get it it's not
supposed to be broken okay I guess the
music the music is done the tuba player
Pat oh no he's back now he passed out
for a little bit late huh huh just did
his drink of water and then oh here oh
no yes I can't go or you can let me
house
hey what Seema what what we came from
upstairs I just came from upstairs what
are you talking about I was just there
who blood was that there before probably
okay well oh no I definitely wasn't now
all right
what hey Louise is that you all right
okay so the guys oh very nice very nice
okay all right okay all right okay all
right okay all right okay all right
great great great Bob okay this is a
goddamn tuba player he needs to work on
his lung capacity oh geez all right well
that's
[Music]
yeah
okay am I free to go
and I just able to walk on my way
where'd my flashlight come from have I
always had that I don't know if you want
to do that okay oh oh
did I do that Oh what the hell whoa way
how are you doing that
how are you doing that that's really
creative how to do that I mean I see the
video game but whatever a flashlight
with UV light I don't want to know what
kind of stains exist in a prison I just
don't want to know that Oh terrible
terrible no hope for us I mean either
all right okay all right anyone in there
haunted toilet yes all right well yeah
you know you gotta admit this game it
don't look too great it doesn't have a
lot in the way a little it doesn't have
a lot in the way it looks but it does
have a lot in the way of like the things
that they're trying to do here it's
definitely rough but as far as like
these indie horror games that are made
by either one person or a very small
team this has come a long way and I've
played a ton of them in my career on
YouTube I've played a ton of them I've
played good I play bad I've played them
all but I gotta applaud them for
actually trying some new things
good duo I don't know if I trust that
that seems like the not thing to do I
can't get it all okay wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute
what the hell how do I get back here all
right oh all right then what the hell
was that
who's busted out of their shell over
there someone's breaking the rules
someone's being naughty hello hi whoa I
don't know this I don't know that code
find the three passwords three passwords
what does that even mean
give me passwords where am I gonna find
those am I gonna loop back around whoa
okay stain all right ah there I go
damn it all right so there's gotta be
codes on the ground
someone had way too much fun in there oh
all right so there's got to be three
codes somewhere
oddly enough the framerate has picked up
and I don't have Hawaii one one I found
a one guys or I have found it found the
one you were looking for the water whoa
okay I heard something
oh that's wait that wasn't like that
before wait that wasn't like that before
wait a minute oh do I just got a loop
through multiple times and like that's
they each have different
they each have differences is that what
it is okay that's still one so there's
gotta be other numbers around here
somewhere oh five I've found a five and
a dead body I found a five and a dead
body
yeah I'm good I'm good I'm good go back
to sleep I'm fine
you are cool very proud of you just go
to hell and die if you're not dead
already just do that please
oh that's so oh the string section is
here all right well that's good one 500
it's the happy chair I'll look at that
smile
look at that award-winning smile on that
chair all right well that's not good
what's in here iy sorry
yeesh
all right anyway okay oh no wait one
five someone's not having a good time in
there hello wait wait wait what he's
real Wow Ella what how what okay find
the wire follow the wire fall the wire
okay yeah see like this is what I mean
that like this is really creative stuff
that is used with like pretty oh there
we go
yes get this dare go I fixed it
fix the problem fix the problem fix the
problem yes no oh wait oh come by me
come behind me so me very much
I'm trapped aw I thought this game was
done oh I thought I thought this was a
whole experience that was interesting
thou is fascinating
very interesting see like it was like I
said it looked very basic looked very
basic okay I already know about this
hang on hands okay so not bad not great
obviously it's very very rough and
anyone would say that I'll say that like
it's just true but they took what what
could have been a very basic horror game
experience and they transformed it into
something even better because they tried
new things and they put just enough
polish on it that it worked well like
the actual experience of the scares
worked very well despite the way it
looked
still rough around the edges but I loved
that that was good it obviously adds
some heart into it and obviously had a
story into it so very cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play this for yourself maybe I
missed a few secrets here and there I'll
put a link in the description and thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought in the comments
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]